of the things that Donald Trump has said a
number of times now to try to convince people
that impeaching him is a bad idea is he's
been saying the stock market would crash if
I got impeached.
Now, it's not a crazy thing to suggest.
Markets in general don't like instability.
The removal of a president or even the attempted
removal of a president is a form of instability,
so it is reasonable to think, wow, if Trump
were impeached, if Trump were impeached and
convicted for removal, the markets would absolutely
crash and Donald Trump has kept pushing this
lately.
He tweeted late last week, quote, if they
actually did this, the markets would crash.
Do you think it was luck that got us to the
best stock market and economy in our history?
It wasn't so put aside for a second that most
stocks are held by relatively few people,
Richard people, and so the level of the stock
market is not the best indicator of the health
of the economy.
Put that aside just for a second.
Okay.
There's a good case to be made that markets
would actually do really well and might even
sore rather than crash if Donald Trump were
impeached.
Rick Newman from Yahoo finance makes the case
for this, and Rick points out that number
one, markets have been relatively stable since
the impeachment inquiry was announced.
You've actually seen very few big swing days
one way or the other since the impeachment
inquiry was announced.
That's the first sign that we should question
this so-called conventional wisdom of impeachment
is terrible for the markets, but Rick Newman
actually says markets would soar if Trump
was impeached because the things that Donald
Trump has done, which tend to boost stocks.
Now this is for better or worse.
This is not me saying I agree with these policies,
but Trump has done tax cuts and deregulation
very often.
That boosts stocks.
Of course, there's [inaudible].
There's an expense to to that as well, which
we can talk about.
Those would in principle stay if Donald Trump
were removed, but a lot of the bad things
Trump has done would likely end the tariffs,
the xenophobia interfering with free markets.
Even on things like immigration.
Immigration is great for the economy.
The gains from immigration, even including
undocumented immigration, are far greater
than the costs to the economy.
Now, this all has a cost to it, right?
Low wages, poor conditions for many legal
and illegal immigrants.
I'm not making a moral analysis here.
I'm merely making an economic one for the
sake of discussion and there is a strong case
to be made that if Donald Trump were impeached
and removed, it would not crash the stock
market the way Donald Trump is pointing out.
Now there is a bigger argument which is if
the right thing to do for legal reasons, on
the basis of the evidence for moral reasons
is to impeach a president.
You do it.
You don't make the calculation that in the
short term the market won't like it, so we
let a president remain president who shouldn't
be president.
That's a separate argument.
What we're talking about merely is the practicality
and the logistics of the market will crash
versus the market will soar if Trump is impeached.
Let me give you another example.
The craziness with Iran.
What's bad for markets is the instability
with Iran, which would probably calm down
if Donald Trump was removed from office.
Now Rick Newman is also saying that if Trump
were replaced with Pence, the economy would
be much better off.
I find Pence disgusting and it would be terrible,
but the main point here that Rick Newman is
making and which I think is is a valid point
to make or at least to propose, is that Donald
Trump's removal would not be terrible for
the economy as a foregone conclusion and we
need to challenge all of those ideas merely
because they might've been accurate 20 years
ago.
Merely because it seems to make some intuitive
sense does not mean that we should fall forward,
hook, line and sinker and more importantly
one way or the other.
This is not the basis on which impeachment
should be decided upon.